質問あるんですけど
皆外国益としたらどこがいいですかああ
僕なんで入れセラーナカって言ったらかっこいいかなんですよ
でねやっぱり二連星の人ってたロンドンなんですけど
エヴァ北へなんか東京とか行ってもなんかあんまり人おおすぎて嫌なんで
ロンドンには行きたくないんです都会に近いぐらいのいわゆる静岡すね
そんな感じのオクスフォードに決めたんですよ
皆さんの留学へ行くとか外国行くとしたらどこに行きたいですかよ
そういうわけで今日はいい
キットカットのクランキーを食べようと思います
妄想関津チョコレート食べすぎて汗が全部同じに感じます
なんであんまり参考にならないんで気にしないで下さいまあ
キットカットですよ maje 形成によくあるきっとカッツみたいな
なんかくねそういう風習があるようですか
まったく面白くありませんねきっとガットの会社さんごめんなさいやいいと思いますよ
そういうキャンペーン
願掛けっていうのはやっぱ気持ちの面で大分変わってくると思うんだよね
愛国は1ブロックがでかいですね
ああ
きちっと絶対に本当な実もん
でもです
まぁちょっと日本のキットカットと牧羊ためで比べてみましょう
ちょっとやっぱ駄目ですね日本のキットカットはまあ食べたことないんですけど
ちょっと雨ですピット
そうそれまあデッカーに比べたら
ハルト上なんだよ
キットカットを食べた方がいいと思います
じゃあ
dea